10 uhr moskauer zeit auf dem roten platz
beginnt ein martialisch anmutende
spektakel der russische
verteidigungsminister schoigu nimmt die
parade zum 77 jahrestag des sieges im
zweiten weltkrieg ab gratuliert den
angetretenen
dann meldungen an präsident putin der
eine kurze ansprache beginnt eine
angebliche bedrohung russlands als
rechtfertigung des angriffs auf die
ukraine
wir hatten gesehen wie eine militärische
infrastruktur entfaltet wurde wie
hunderte ausländische berater zu
arbeiten begannen regelmäßige
lieferungen modernster waffen aus den
nato-ländern erfolgten die bedrohungen
damit jedem tag zu russland hat der
aggression eine präventive abfuhr
erteilt
der kampf der sowjetunion gegen
nazi-deutschland gleichgesetzt mit dem
angriff auf ein demokratisch verfasstes
nachbarland in dem angeblich faschisten
an der macht seien bei vielen in
russland fällt diese erzählung auf
fruchtbaren boden
ich denke dass wir damit fertig werden
dass wir noch einen tag des sieges haben
ich denke dass dies alles der wunsch
amerikas ist unser land in seinen besitz
zu bringen und all unsere bodenschätze
und reichtümer zu bekommen denn das was
wir besitzen bewegt sie sehr unter
anderem das erdgas
wie viele russische soldaten und
offiziere bisher in der ukraine gefallen
sind ist unklar doch wladimir putin will
vorbeugen wenn die zahl der särge die
aus der ukraine zurück kommen immer
größer wird verspricht den
hinterbliebenen großzügige hilfen
der staat die regionen wie unternehmen
und gesellschaftlichen organisationen
werden alles tun um solche familien mit
fürsorge zu umgeben um ihnen zu helfen
besondere unterstützung werden wir den
kindern der gefallenen und verwundeten
kampfgefährten gewähren ein
präsidentenerlass ist dazu heute
unterzeichnet haben
dabei sind es vor allem soldaten aus dem
fernen osten und dem süden russlands die
in der ukraine kämpfen moskau oder st
petersburger bleiben vorerst verschont
vor allem weil dann proteste in den
russischen zentren befürchtet werden
gut 90 minuten dauerte die parade auf
dem roten platz in moskau die
feierlichkeiten in der russischen
hauptstadt und im ganzen land gehen noch
weiter bis in den abend und
unser korrespondent christian senn
beobachtet die feierlichkeiten zum 77
jahrestag des sieges über die deutsche
nazi herrschaft die parade in moskau die
haben wir gerade gesehen die haben sie
verfolgt welche bedeutung hat dieser tag
in russland an
neunter meint er ist tatsächlich noch
einer der wichtigsten feiertage für ganz
viele russinnen und russen haben das
heute auch wieder gesehen hier rund um
die parade da sind familien komplett
gekommen zusammen
geschmückt mit patriotischem
habseligkeiten und zeichnen zum beispiel
gibt es diese dieses abzeichen aus dem
krieg
gleichzeitig auch die unterstützung mit
der politik von präsident putin
symbolisieren soll wir haben mit einigen
menschen auch gesprochen schon beim
training her zur parade und haben viele
gesagt dieser feiertag der ist uns sehr
wichtig wir wollen an die helden von
damals erinnern wir möchten nicht dass
dieser historische feiertag verknüpft
wird mit aktuellen ereignissen und genau
das hat präsident putin teilweise in
seiner rede heute ja getan vor der rede
hatten ja einige beobachter befürchtet
putin könnte eine art und
generalmobilmachung verkünden also
reservisten einberufen und vielleicht
den einsatz in der ukraine ausweiten das
ist jetzt erstmal so nicht geschehen in
wie weit ist das dann vielleicht ein
zeichen der deeskalation
ich will auch sagen das war
bemerkenswert wenn man die verschiedenen
szenarien sie haben sie gerade
angesprochen vorher diskutiert hat
konnte man hier von einigem ausgehen
dass zeigt erstmal doch ganz deutlich
dass man bis zum schluss immer nicht
weiß was wladimir putin wirklich macht
und was er verkünden wird das ist eine
deeskalation ist so weit würde ich nicht
gehen er hat vielmehr nochmal
altbekanntes wiederholt und hat gesagt
warum russland sozusagen gar keine
andere wahl hatte als diese in version
zu führen in der ukraine hat noch einmal
betont dass russland massiv bedroht
worden sei er durch die ukraine und
durch die nato und dass diese in version
eigentlich unumgänglich war also ich
will nicht sagen dass das eine die sks
die eskalation war vor allem auch nicht
wenn man nochmal beachtet dass er auch
die opferfamilien angesprochen hat also
die familien von möglicherweise
gefallenen soldaten jetzt in diesem
konflikt in der ukraine dabei wird ja
immer ein großes geheimnis gemacht wie
viele opfer es tatsächlich gegeben hat
habe ich denke wenn wladimir putin das
auf der großen bühne jetzt noch mal so
anspricht kann man sich darauf
einstellen dass die opferzahlen hoch
sind dass hatte keine sprecher peskow
vor einigen wochen auch schon mal betont
ohne konkrete zahlen zu nennen aber ich
glaube wladimir putin hat das eigene
volk jetzt noch mal auf einen längeren
konflikt eingestimmt einschätzung von
unserem korrespondenten in moskau
christian seinen vielen dank
und genau über dieses thema sprechen wir
jetzt mit der sicherheits expertin der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik mit
claudia major schönen guten tag guten
tag frau major wir haben eben gerade
darüber gesprochen die
generalmobilmachung über die viele
spekuliert hatten vor diesem neunten mal
die ist jetzt erstmal nicht gekommen ja
wie überrascht sind sie
es gab in der tat die erwartung dass das
putin auf dieser rede noch mal mehr
eskalieren würde aber es braucht auch
nicht die rede am 9 mai um weitere
schritte anzukündigen
generalmobilmachung oder auch nochmal
nuclear säbel zu rasseln das heißt es
braucht die rede nicht er kann auch
andere gelegenheiten dazu dazu nutzen
und man muss auch ganz klar sagen es gab
in dieser rede keine zeichen von
deeskalation sondern die klassischen
russischen narrativer russland wäre
bedroht sie kämpft gegen faschismus die
wurden alle bestätigt also eigentlich
ist wie vorher also sie sagen wie vorher
das heißt also es gibt eigentlich keinen
neuen sieg male aus dieser rede für den
westen oder für russland selbst
beurteilen sie das also ich sehe vor
allem eine bestätigung der klassischen
erklärungsansätze nämlich zu sagen
russland musste sich verteidigen
russlands sicherheitsinteressen wurden
nicht wahrgenommen
es musste sich gegen die aggression aus
dem westen verteidigen und es ist ein
kampf gegen den faschismus er hat auch
diese traditionslinie gezogen zwischen
den vorfahren dem zweiten weltkrieg
gekämpft haben gegen den faschismus und
jetzt wieder in der ukraine also hat
dieses ideologische bindemittel kampf
gegen den faschismus genutzt und das ist
eine klare wie vorher linie also
anzeichen ich fragt trotzdem noch mal
wenn natürlich die hoffnung immer da ist
diesen konflikt irgendwie nächster zeit
beilegen zu können ansatzpunkte für
diplomatische gespräche haben sie nicht
gefunden habe ich in dieser rede nicht
gefunden und man kann sich auch das ende
der rede angucken das endet mit auf den
sieg und auf russland und in der ganzen
heer leitung in der rede sehe ich kann
er der anzeichen für die eskalation
sondern eher eine bestätigung dafür dass
es ein richtiger kampf ist er lobt die
heroischen kämpfe der soldaten da es
keinerlei anzeichen irgendwie davon
zurückzutreten putin warnte auch vor
einem globalen krieg das hat er auch
immer wieder angesprochen wie sollte
europa die usa ich sag jetzt mal der
westen auf diese rede reagieren
ich denke dass die westlichen staaten
gemeinsam reagieren sollten und
eigentlich an ihrer linie bislang
festhalten sollten das heißt die ukraine
stark zu unterstützen mit den
militärischen gütern aber auch
finanziell mit humanitärer hilfe die
sanktionen fortsetzen aber diese rote
linie selber nicht direkt zu
intervenieren an den die nato und auch
die westlichen staaten festhalten an der
die sollte weiterhin bestehen bleiben
also eigentlich wie vor eher ein
ausgewogenes vorgehen große
unterstützung ohne die rote linie
direkter intervention aber bräuchte
putin zweifelt diese rote linie oder ist
es nicht so dass man das gefühl hat er
ist eigentlich unabhängig davon und
entscheidet nach seinen überlegungen
russland entscheidet wann es sich
provoziert fühlt und russland oder putin
hat auch sehr klar gemacht dass es sich
bereit in einem bereits in einem krieg
mit den westlichen staaten oder an einem
konflikt nicht in einem konflikt mit den
westlichen staaten sieht also denken sie
stimmt es ist also ist es seine eigene
einschätzung ein mittel was ihr eben
schon angesprochen haben sind auch die
sanktion inwieweit sehen sie denn dass
die wirken
von dem was wir wissen wirken sie
tatsächlich schon auf die russische
wirtschaft wir sehen aber auch dass
putin versucht diese effekte zu sagen
wegzuwischen er hat heute auch in der
rede unterstützung für die familien von
gefallenen soldaten angekündigt es gab
auch andere unterstützungszahlungen das
heißt er versucht trotzdem die effekte
auf die bevölkerung gering zu halten
weil das natürlich auch an an seiner
zustimmung seiner psychologischen wie
lang ist das denn möglich denn im grunde
sagt ja der westen immer wir haben schon
sehr sehr starke sanktionen in kraft
gesetzt sanktionen wirken langfristig
das heißt sie können auf das akute
kriegsgeschehen jetzt haben sie relativ
wenig einfluss sie wirken langfristig
auf die die kraft russlands
beispielsweise auch um die
rüstungsindustrie am laufen zu halten um
die wirtschaft am laufen zu halten das
heißt wann das kippt es sehr schwer
vorherzusagen sagt die sicherheits
expertin der stiftung wissenschaft und
politik claudia major vielen dank für
das gespräch gerne